so i'm curious about how much
acceleration does a pilot or the pilot
and the plane experience when it when
they need to take off from an aircraft
carrier so i looked up a few statistics
on the internet this right here is a
picture of an fa18 hornet right over
here it has a takeoff speed of 260
kilometers per hour if we want that to
be a velocity 260 kilometers per hour in
this direction if it's taking off from
this nimitz class carrier right over
here and i also looked it up and i found
the runway length or i should say the
catapult length because these planes
don't take off just with their own power
they have their own thrusters going but
they also are catapulted off so they can
be really accelerated quickly off of the
flight deck of this carrier and the
runway length of a nimitz class carrier
is about 80 meters so this is where they
take off from this right over here is
where they take off from and then they
come in and they land over here but i'm
curious about the takeoff
so to do this let's figure out let's
well let's just figure out the
acceleration and from that we could also
figure out how long it takes them to be
catapulted off the flight deck so let me
get the numbers in one place so the
takeoff velocity i could say is 260
kilometers per hour
so let me write this down so that has to
be your final velocity when you're
getting off of the plane if you want to
be flying
so your initial velocity is going to be
zero and once again i'm going to use the
convention that the the direction of the
vector is implicit positive means going
in the direction of takeoff negative
would mean going the other way
my initial velocity is zero i'll denote
it as a vector right here my final
velocity
my final velocity over here has to be
260 kilometers per hour and i want to
convert everything to meters and seconds
just so that i can get my
use it at least for meters so i can use
my runway length in meters so let's just
do it in meters per second i have a
feeling it'll be a little bit easier to
understand when we talk about
acceleration in those units as well
so if we want to convert this into
seconds we have we'll put hours in the
numerator 1 hour so it cancels out with
this hour is equal to 3 600 seconds
3 600 seconds i'll just write 3 600 s
and then if we want to convert it to
meters
we have 1000 meters 1000 meters is equal
to one
is equal to one kilometer this one
kilometer will cancel out with those
kilometers right over there and whenever
you're doing any type of this
dimensional analysis you should really
should see whether it makes sense if i'm
going 260 kilometers in an hour
i should go much fewer kilometers in a
second because the second is so much a
shorter amount of time and that's why
we're dividing by 3 600. if i can go a
certain number of kilometers in an hour
a second i should be able to go a lot
many many many more meters in that same
amount of time and that's why we're
multiplying by a thousand but you
multiply these out the hours cancel out
you have the kilometers cancelling out
and you have 260 times a thousand
divided by 3600 meters per second so let
me get my trusty ti-85 out
and actually calculate that i have over
here so i have 260
260 times a thousand
times one thousand
divided by
divided by thirty six hundred
divided by thirty six hundred gets me
i'll just round it to seventy two
because that's about how many
significant digits i can assume here
72 meters per second so all i did here
is i converted the takeoff velocity so
this is 72
meters per second this has to be the
final velocity after accelerating
so let's think about what that
acceleration could be given that we know
the the length of the runway and we're
going to assume constant acceleration
here just to simplify things a little
bit but what does that constant
acceleration have to be
so let's think a little bit about it the
total displacement i'll do that in
purple the total displacement is going
to be equal to
is going to be equal to our average
velocity while we're accelerating times
the time
times the time the difference in time or
the amount of time that takes us to
accelerate
now what is the average velocity here
it's going to be our final velocity plus
our initial velocity over 2 it's just
the average of the initial and final and
we can only do that because we are
dealing with a constant acceleration and
what is our change in time over here
what is it our change in time well our
change in time is how long does it take
us to get to that to get to that
velocity or another way to think about
it is it is our change in velocity
divided by our acceleration if we're
trying to get to if we're trying to get
to 10 meters per second and we're or
we're trying to get 10 meters per second
faster and we're accelerating at 2
meters per second squared it'll take us
5 seconds or if you want to see that
explicitly written in a formula
we know that acceleration is equal to
change in velocity over
change in time you multiply both sides
by change in time and you divide both
sides by acceleration so let's do that
multiply both sides by change in time
and divide by acceleration
multiply by change in time and divide by
acceleration
and you get that cancels out and then
you have that cancelled out and you have
change in time is equal to change in
velocity divided by acceleration
change in velocity divided by
acceleration so what's the change in
velocity
change in velocity so this is going to
be change in velocity
divided by acceleration change in
velocity is the same thing as your final
velocity
minus your initial velocity all of that
divided by acceleration so this delta t
part we can rewrite as our final
velocity
minus our initial velocity minus our
initial velocity over acceleration and
just doing this simple little derivation
here actually gives us a pretty cool
result
if we just
if we just work through this math and
i'll try to write a little bigger i see
my right is getting my writing is
getting smaller our displacement can be
expressed as the product of these two
things and what's cool about this well
let me just write it this way so this is
v our final velocity
plus our initial velocity
times
our final velocity minus our initial
velocity all of that over
all of that over two times our
acceleration our assumed constant
our assumed constant acceleration and
you probably remember from algebra class
this is it takes the form a plus b times
a minus b
and so this is equal to and you can
multiply it out if and you can review in
our algebra playlist how to multiply out
two binomials like this but this
numerator right over here i'll write it
in blue is going to be equal to our
final velocity squared minus our initial
velocity squared
this is a difference of squares you can
factor it out into the sum of the of the
two terms times the difference of the
two terms so that when you multiply
these two out you just get that over
there over over two times the
acceleration
over two times the acceleration
now what's really cool here is we were
able to derive a formula that just deals
with the displacement our final velocity
our initial velocity and the
acceleration and we know all of those
things except for the acceleration we
know that our displacement is 80 meters
we know that this is 80 meters we know
that our final velocity just before we
square it we know that our final
velocity is 72 meters per second
72 meters per second and we know that
our initial velocity is zero meters per
second and so we can use all of this
information to solve for our
acceleration
so and you could you might see this
formula displacement sometimes called
distance if you're just viewing the
scalar version and really we are
thinking only in the scalar we're
thinking about the magnitudes of all of
these things for the sake of this video
we're only dealing in one dimension
but sometimes you'll see it written like
this sometimes you'll multiply both
sides times the 2a and you'll get
something like this where you have 2
times
the really the magnitude of the
acceleration times
the magnitude of the displacement which
is the same thing as the distance is
equal to
the final velocity
the magnitude of the final velocity
squared
but we're assuming this is so the final
velocity squared minus
minus the initial velocity squared or
sometimes in some books it'll be written
as 2ad is equal to vf squared minus vi
squared it seems like the super
mysterious thing but it's not that
mysterious we just very simply derived
it from
displacement or if you want to say
distance if you're just thinking about
the scalar quantity is equal to average
velocity times change in time so so far
we've just derived ourselves a kind of a
neat formula that is often not derived
in physics class but let's use it to
actually figure out the acceleration
that a pilot experiences when they're
taking off of a nimitz class carrier
so we have 2
times the acceleration times the
distance that's 80 meters times 80
meters is going to be equal to our final
velocity squared what's our final
velocity 72 meters per second
so 72 meters per second
squared minus our initial velocity so
our initial velocity in this situation
is just zero so it's just going to be
minus zero squared which is just going
to be zero so we don't even have to
write it down
and so to solve for acceleration to
solve for acceleration you just divide
so this is the same thing as 160 meters
well let's just divide both sides by 2
times 80. so we get acceleration
is equal to
is equal to 72 meters per second
squared over
2 times 80 over 2 times 80 meters
2 times 80 meters and what we're going
to get is and i'll just write this in
one color it's going to be 72 divided by
times
we have in the numerator meter squared
over second squared we're squaring the
units meter squared over second squared
and then we're going to we're going to
be dividing by meters so times this in
blue
times 1 over meters right because we
have a meters in the denominator and so
what we're going to get is
this meter squared divided by meters
that's going to cancel out we're going
to get meters per second squared which
is cool because that's what acceleration
should be in
and so let's just get the calculator out
to calculate this exact acceleration
so we have to take
oh sorry this is 72 squared let me let
me write that down so this is
this is going to be 72 squared don't
want to forget about this part right
over here 72 squared divided by 160.
so we have
and we can just use the original number
right over here that we calculated so
let's just square that
and then divide that by 160 divided by
160 and if we go to two significant
digits we get 33
we get our acceleration
is our acceleration is equal to 33
meters per second squared
and just to give you an idea of how much
acceleration that is is if you are in
free fall over earth
the the the earth the force of gravity
will be accelerating you at you so g
is going to be equal to 9.8 meters per
second squared so this is accelerating
you three times
three times more than what earth is
making you accelerate if you were to
jump off of a cliff or something so
another way to think about this is that
the the force and we haven't done a lot
on force yet we'll talk about this more
in more depth is that this pilot would
be experiencing more than three times
the force of gravity more than three g's
three g's would be about 30 meters per
second squared this is more than that so
an analog an analogy for how the pilot
would feel
is when he's you know if this is the
chair right here that is his pilot's
chair that he's in so this is the chair
and he's sitting on the chair
let me do my best to draw him sitting on
the chair
so this is him sitting on the chair
flying the plane
and this is the pilot
the force he would feel
or while this thing is accelerating him
forward at 33 meters per second squared
it would feel very much to him like as
if he was lying down on the surface of
the planet but he was three times
heavier or more than three times heavier
or if he if he was lying down and he's
you know if you were lying down like
this let's say this is you this is your
feet
and this is your face
this is your hands let me draw your
hands right here and if you had if you
had essentially two more people stacked
above you roughly i'm just giving you
the general sense of it that's how it
would feel a little bit more than two
people that squeezing sensation so his
entire body is going to feel
three times heavier than it would if he
was just laying down on the beach or
something like that so it's a very very
very interesting um i guess idea at
least to me now the other question that
we can ask ourselves is how long will it
take to get catapulted off of this off
of this carrier and if he's accelerating
at 33 meters per second squared if he's
accelerating at 33 meters per second
squared how long would it take him to go
from zero to 72 meters per second so
after one second he'll be going 33
meters per second after two seconds
he'll be going 66 meters per second so
it's going to take and so it's a little
bit more than two seconds so it's going
to take him a little bit more than two
seconds and we can calculate it exactly
if you take 72 meters per second and you
divide it by 33
it'll take him 2.18 seconds roughly to x
to be catapulted off of that carrier